ça se passait de même oye mba dyarchie
ve
c'est un voyage dans le temps qui nous
replonge dans les débuts télévisuels de
rock et belles oreilles à l'époque où le
groupe ses visées sur les ondes de tqs
ça s'intitule avec reconnu pour son
humour corrosif r b ou a choisi de
placer une mise en garde au début de
chaque épisode pour avertir que
certaines blagues pourrait heurter la
sensibilité des auditeurs où il ya des
enfants qu'on a enlevé la fin qu'on se
dise garde
c'est embêtant c'est dans la voûte en
quelque part pour l'instant on s'en
passe on sent pas que c'est pertinent de
présenter ces images mais c'est ce que
tout ce qui est jean les jobs de gros
noms savait que les docks de titres
encore correct mode de ce que je sens il
n'ya pas vraiment moi je suis un ancien
maigre et puis je suis toujours
discriminer les jeunes hommes barbus
induirait des herbiers ou quarante ans
plus tard
mon dieu seigneur probablement qu'on
ferait des parodies extrêmement cruelle
mais je pense avec une certaine
affection parce que il ya la méchanceté
chez nous à toujours était gratuite et
elle était appliquée de façon équitable
et inclusive
on la méchanceté et la méchanceté plein
d'amour non mais c'est vrai c'est tout à
fait vrai
[Musique]
pour ma part j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir
à me plonger dans une ère de renouveau
de cette époque passée j'ai l'impression
que on a besoin de nostalgie de revoir
cette belle époque où y'avait pas de
coronavirus on pouvait simplement rire
de tout de façon affreuse bête et
méchante en faisant réfléchir et parce
que toi lui fait depuis mais tu étais
déjà un fan fini convaincu avant même
les premières secondes
moi je me souviens d'avoir écouté le
premier épisode de r b o à 86
j'avais 9 ans visites de jeunes est
monsieur caron strangl et donc de
replonger là-dedans trente ans plus tard
c'est comme vraiment magique c'est la
nostalgie à l'état pur par contre en
écoutant sa 43 ans je trouve très acide
très méchant je me demande si je vais
faire que ça mon fils andré parce que
baudreix par exemple gérard la barre m
bel gazou 5-0 à grand chose et
participent à ces recherches
quand mes parents je vais lui montrer
l'expression de strangl ça c'est
m'arrache ya par centre qui touche à
mareuil l'écart a peur d'un bios est à
découvrir sur cris d' ici n'est bien
alexandre lortie et louis-philippe oui
mais radio-canada montréal doudou
doudoune ou